the ukrainians are saying that the
Chernobyl plant is now in the hands of
the Russians I'm joined by our security
and defense editor Deborah Haynes so
highly significant for many reasons not
least that it's not far from here yeah
Lotus most direct route to the capital
and we've had a as well as what you've
just been talking about an update from
the UK's Ministry of Defense their
defense intelligence agency which is
producing very unusually information
because they obviously want to try and
cut through the disinformation that's go
that's out there and they're saying that
they believe that Russian forces are
moving towards Kiev so significant in
the sense that it's been taken and it's
close to here but also just dangerous in
the fact that it was the site of
um you know the were one of the worst
man-made disasters in our time and the
the Ukrainian president and he took to
Twitter to call out what was going on
there's been fighting there going on for
a few hours he said that the um the
occupation forces are trying to seize
the plant he said that our Defenders are
giving their lives so the tragedy of
1986 will not be repeating did and he
said that he's reported this to the
Swedish prime minister and then that
this is a declaration of war against the
whole of Europe so clearly it's you know
it's it's a nucleus a radioactive site
it's highly sensitive the idea that
you've got a war going on there is is
incredibly uncomfortable probably more
uncomfortable right now in the short
term is the idea that Russian troops
seem to be moving towards the capital
that certainly seems to be what is
happening and more broadly uh Deborah I
mean what is happening in this
extraordinary unprovoked attack on a
sovereign state in Europe what is how
what are the what is the state of play
are the ukrainians resisting yes they
are I mean we're about 13 hours into the
invasion you'll remember we were woken
up to the sound of loud explosions in
the distance from here as key targets
were taken out by the Russian military
we understand it was Precision missile
strikes as well as air strikes going
against command and control centers so
areas that would be used to command the
Ukrainian armed forces and also
Ukraine's air defense systems that's
significant because if the Russian
military are able to disable ukrainian's
ability to shoot their aircraft out of
the sky it gives them that dominance to
be able to operate more freely in the
airspace over here and obviously then
strike against Ukrainian targets at the
same time we've seen pictures haven't we
of troops tanks rolling across the
border not just in Belarus not just from
Belarus rather in the north but also
coming from Crimea that Peninsula that
was annexed by Russia back in 2014
there's fighting in person one which is
a large strategically important region
that sits on the Black Sea of clashes
going on right now down there and then
at the same time as that we understand
the Ukrainian military is putting up a
strong resistance but that there are
heavy casualties on both sides and we
don't have the most recent numbers on
that but a huge huge battle for this
country is underway right now and what
we can say tonight is that this is a
fully fledged invasion of this country
and can we also say with the purpose of
removing the democratically elected
government here it certainly seems that
that has to be the intent
um this this is not a limited incursion
which some people thought might be the
most likely uh outcome if President
Putin did decide to go for the military
option the fact that they are striking
north east south across the country
multiple targets going after like I said
those command and control centers also
there have been explosions that we've
seen around power plants as well
um the sort of a dam that we've seen the
military moving around there which means
an intent to take control of critical
National infrastructure that is also
incredibly important if you want to
[ __ ] a government if you want to
bring a country to its knees you don't
just go after the military you also go
after the basic Services power light
electricity the Internet it's still
working here at the moment but we can
expect that to be impacted in the coming
hours maybe days but this is happening
incredibly quickly the fact that you now
have Russian forces moving towards Kiev
unimaginable just just 24 hours ago